the debate between people who call
themselves originalist s-- and everybody
else is about whether that we can
discern that meaning by staring hard at
the words or whether we need to apply
our own understanding of the world in
which we live it would make a difference
if the Commerce Clause was enforced
according to its original meaning if the
Necessary and Proper Clause was enforced
according to its original meaning if the
Second Amendment was enforced according
to its original meaning the fact that
there's no Equal Rights Amendment in the
Constitution is a reflection of the fact
that our contemporary society accepted
women's equality and so there was no
need to amend the Constitution if those
provisions are so open-ended that they
could be construed to mean anything that
we want them to mean then why did they
have to be redacted well welcome to this
tenth debate of the second season of the
solo forum at the subculture Theatre in
downtown Manhattan I'm Jean Epstein
director of the Sola forum we're a
monthly debate series that features
topics of special interest to
libertarians and aims to enhance social
and professional ties within New York
City's libertarian community we're
partnered with Reason magazine in
promoting these debates and in and you
can catch audio and video of our events
on the reason podcast which you'll find
in the iTunes Store as a special bonus
this evening reason is making available
its current issue of its magazine with
the title burned after reading you won't
want to miss this it includes reasons
classic pot brownies reasons a recipe
for prison hooch
how to get on the jury outlaw mags
exactly the kind of material we want to
present tonight because we've got
lawyers in the room and also another
article called don't let Uncle Sam seize
your salami so you don't want to miss
out on that and you want to get a
subscription to reason
magazine I read it faithfully every
month myself this is an Oxford style
debate in which the audience initially
votes for against or undecided on the
resolution and then again after the
debate is over whoever moves the vote in
his or a favor is declared the winner go
into solo vote.com to cast your initial
vote you'll find that tonight's
resolution reads the US Constitution
should be interpreted and applied
according to the original meaning
communicated to the public by the words
of the text now with every cell form we
have a warm-up act and this evening
we're pleased to bring back Dave Smith
who runs the great podcast part of the
problem Dave please come to the stage
and warm us up
oh hello hello am i on what's going on
everybody how about another hand for
Jean Epstein huh puts these wonderful
events together oh this is a this is an
exciting one man I've been to a lot of
these things but this one I'm pumped for
and you got free copies of Reason
magazine everybody just hold that in
your hand and know you are holding the
biggest book gary johnson ever read and
that is he got all the way through that
he mostly looks at the pictures but he
enjoyed it and i huh I don't know why I
can't help myself sometimes though I
love Reason magazine don't cut out my
intro this time alright so one saw me
taking shots at Cato alright what a
great time we have the one of my
favorite human beings on the planet
celebrity Rhian Judge Napolitano
moderating tonight's debate we're all
honored and he would be here Judge
Napolitano or as MSNBC refers to him a
Russian spy and I don't know I haven't
gotten to the bottom of it yet you have
to forgive MSNBC they just they hate
Russia they're really pissed off at
Russia there's still some sort feelings
ever since they abandoned communism and
that's just it's fresh wounds for MSNBC
they have a lot of the Constitution
we're here to talk about right the our
founding document the Constitution was
written to restrain the power of the
state and I don't know if you've checked
but it's doing a great job and it's
doing just just what it was intended to
do I I saw Donald Trump the other day
they asked him you know what he was
gonna do and he was like I got a check
article 1 section hey before before I do
anything
make sure I relay okay of course I mean
the Constitution is still very relevant
today we did we elected a brilliant
orator who taught constitutional law
still talking about Trump it was at
Trump University
he gave the consent it was a Benjamin
Franklin supposedly he said right when
he came out and they said what have you
given us right some lady was like by the
way that lady sounds pretty pushy in the
story right it's like what have you
given us like Jesus I'm working but
she's like what and what did he say
right he said a republic if you can keep
it I don't you kind of wish you were
right there when he said that and you
were just like listen we're not gonna be
able to keep this thing so you really
like you got you're gonna have to
rethink this whole idea and then I think
it was Thomas Jefferson who said
something like I don't I always butcher
these quotes but it was something like
the tree of liberty has to be watered
with the blood of tyrants and you know
Patriots oh okay oh that well I liked my
version better sorry
was it Patriots what do we always have
to die whatever happen I don't know if
you've seen that tree but there's not a
lot of new leafy growth on it it's uh
it's looking by the way I don't even
know I don't even believe that any of
the founders said half the stuff we
credit to them I'm like I'm
conspiratorial about that Henry Ford
definitely didn't say half the things we
give him credit for no one person had
that many great quotes I don't believe
it and also while I'm getting into
conspiracy
I don't think Ben Affleck and Matt Damon
wrote Good Will Hunting I don't believe
for a second okay there's no way they
wrote that really they put out that
masterpiece and then just crap for the
rest of their careers like I don't
it doesn't make set at 22 they banged
out that masterpiece it's like it's like
if Shakespeare just like wrote one
Shakespeare nut and then it was like
just three Bourne identities after that
like I don't know I don't think this is
the same guy probably but that's just me
I don't mean to go all conspiratorial on
you guys really but really the
Constitution was a conspiracy that's how
this whole country started right it was
just like a few guys who are like we're
tired of this we're gonna start our own
government you know they're really
they're like the original Zionists if
you think about it but I can't all right
thanks 3 Jews let's move off that touchy
subject all right moving moving right
along I do I don't know I've always kind
of thought like the Constitution is is
kind of like I mean I like it I I read
it it's good book but I just don't you
know it doesn't seem like it applies
that much anymore no one follows it you
know but then like Europe started
locking up every blog or they don't like
and I was like I'm pretty into that
First Amendment thing that's pretty cool
I'm glad we have that and also I'm glad
we don't we don't have royalty like that
just for that alone it's worth it
getting right how do people still obsess
over like the prince getting married and
stuff like that like this isn't that the
most disrespectful thing to everyone who
died in the revolution you know the last
just war that we thought
wasn't that well to be fair the South
had a pretty good argument but that's
come on if I can't say it here where am
I gonna be able to say stuff like that
freakin northern meddlers let him go but
really we still got to watch that like I
was in Canada but recently in Toronto
and they still have the Queen on their
money and just that alone I feel like
it's worth fighting a war over just to
not have that stupid Queen on our money
like don't you hate I just it's like
she's not a queen she's just some lady
she's just some old lady who everybody
is telling her that she's a queen and
then like when you talk to like English
people they're like yeah we have a queen
but it's just like for tradition we
don't really have a queen but you have a
queen you can't have a queen in 2018
like you shouldn't have a queen and the
Internet at the same time well you
should have one or the other usually
have to give up Internet if you're still
gonna have a queen okay and does she
know like does the Queen really know
that she's not a real queen or does she
just think she's being super cool about
her powers like she's an old lady
maybe she's ghost senile and starts
thinking she's a real quick-like what
would happen in England if tomorrow the
Queen just came out and was like I
declare war we're all going to war now
like does everyone in England just like
yes we got to go to war because the
Queen or are they like now someone's got
a tower be like hey we've just kind of
been humoring you this whole time it's
you're not really a queen or maybe a
queen just sends them to what I don't
think a queen is gonna be prepared for
modern war there's like here's a sword
and a Bible good luck like
I don't know maybe if we could go back
in time and talk to the founders we'd be
like you should be proud
don't worry give it a couple hundred
years but soon this great nation will
send Dennis Rodman to bring peace in the
Koreas finally this whole thing will
come together and we will man we are any
of you guys feel like we're like in one
of those movies where there's like like
someone has a time machine and then they
go back and they mess up and then like
you come to the Future that was never
supposed to be and like like Dennis
Rodman's in North Korea
like what like someone's someone needs
to come back and fix everything and
you're like oh yeah that made more sense
okay yeah yeah Ron Paul won in 2020 and
into an everything is fine or whatever
2012 whatever you ran yeah a few sad Ron
Paul supporters out there he's still
doing good don't worry is it great that
like like Kim jong-un and Donald Trump
can actually sit down like for all the
things that any of us may not like about
Donald Trump
you know like Kim jong-un looked at him
and he was like finally America's making
some sense like I can't believe it
finally picked a serious leader after
all these years of joking around with
these clowns there's like so I want like
make it like I feel like like they're
gonna sit down and then everyone else is
gonna leave the room and then they're
just gonna like look at each other and
they'll be like is it just us is it just
us and then they're just like dude I
think you're awesome and it's like it's
right for me to mad that is hilarious
what you're doing on Twitter we don't
have Twitter or food but we do I love
what you guys are doing all right hey
man I am uh I know you all you guys are
I'm very excited to get this thing
started I always love coming here so
thanks for having me enjoy the night
everybody and
[Applause]
[Music]
Dave Smith you should listen to his
podcast part of the problem it's really
great well with we now go to the main
event arguing for the affirmative on the
resolution we have Georgetown Law
Professor Randy Barnett Randy please
come to the stage arguing for the
negative we have Cornell Law Professor
Michael Dorf Mike please come to the
stage and acting as guest moderator for
the evenings debate we have the judge
who needs no introduction Judge Andrew
Napolitano judge please take over Dave
Smith we have a tough act to follow Wow
so you probably know the rules professor
Barnett will speak first for 12 and a
half minutes and then professor Dorf and
then they can rebut each other then
we'll get to questions and then they'll
do a final summation we'll stick pretty
close to the time period they'll all be
a little bit flexible you understand the
proposition which professor Barnett will
define he'll tell you what originalism
is or at least his understanding of it
and he'll make that argument and of
course we can expect the counter from
Professor Dorothy this is a very very
hot topic in law schools particularly
since the mortal demise of Justice
Scalia who is credited with at least
bringing it to our consciousness some
would say he failed because the court
never really went along with it some
would say succeeded beyond as to what
his wildest imaginings to have
intellects like our two debaters and all
of you listening over the topic of
originalism it's not a word I would use
at Fox because it's a different kind of
audience but here we're
beat it around and beat it to death and
explain it and explore it professor
Bernette the floor is yours in defense
of the proposition thank you thank you
judge Napolitano thanks Jean for
inviting me how about another hand for
Dave Smith isn't he fantastic I just
wanted him to argue my side you know
that's all right I think he could do
better than I do
it's a very pleasure to be on a panel
that's moderated by my friend judgment
of 'allah tano and also to be debating
my other friend Mike Dorf who I've known
for many many years and to be here for
the first time I thought I'd start off
by talking about how I became an
originalist because I wasn't an
originalist for most of my career I
started in law school I had a law
professor who is actually a close
collaborator professor Doris Larry tribe
was my law professor and after I took
Larry tribe for con law I just sort of
said that was it for con law for me I
didn't want anything to do with the
Constitution after that and it wasn't
Professor tribes fault he was a great
professor is that when I went through
the case book and I turned the pages and
I would get to a part of the
Constitution like the ninth amendment
for example that said something I liked
and then I turned the page of the case
book and I'd find out that the Supreme
Court said it really didn't mean
anything or we were not going to we're
not going to enforce that provision and
we're not gonna enforce that provision
and so by the time I was done with my
constitutional law class I was done with
constitutional law frankly and when I
became a law I went to practice I was a
criminal prosecutor in Chicago when I
went into teaching I became a contracts
professor because in contracts you know
writings still matter you still
interpret writings you still follow
writings it matters what you sign and so
that's what I was and then inadvertently
I sort of got pulled into constitutional
I won't tell the story about how that
happened but I want to tell the story of
how I became a an originalist because I
wasn't I had Ronald Dworkin with my
professor in law school I would have to
say that if I was anything I was at work
any and when it came to constitutional
interpretation and and and the reason
was is that everything I heard about
originalism I thought was wrong I
thought I didn't it to it I mean I did
understand why we should be bound by the
framers of the Constitution what
authority did these framers have over us
and not only that but there were these
practical problems with originalism
figuring out what the framers intended
originalism I actually wrote an article
critical of originalism in which I
characterized this view as the framers
as our wardens that there are keepers
and there somehow have to control us and
that the way that we would decide
constitutional cases is by channeling
the framers as in old framers would you
think that the thermal imaging of a
house to detect increased heat emanating
from it indicating marijuana cultivation
is a search tell us framers do you think
that it is nowadays that goes under the
rubric of what would Madison do you
decide questions based on what was
Madison doing because of these problems
with originalism I myself was not one
and then I was teaching a seminar on
constitutional law at Boston University
and there was a footnote in one of the
readings I I said head assigned and it
was a footnote to a man named Lysander
Spooner now how many of you have heard
of Lysander Spooner I can't see you
because of the lights you gonna have to
applaud if you've heard it because I
can't see any man so if you've heard of
Lysander Spooner you probably know his
famous article which I read in college
called the no trees in the constitution
of no authority which I read in college
and I like very much and so I'm teaching
this class and there's a footnote and
the footnote says C Lysander Spooner the
unconstitutionality of slavery 19 1846
well maybe was 18 1845 and I'm thinking
Lysander Spooner wrote about the
unconstitutionality of slavery in 1845
this is 20 years before the the 13th
amendment ratified what could he
possibly have said so I had the library
bring me a copy of it it turns out it
was in the sixth volume and collected
works of Lysander Spooner little did I
know that he wrote anything other than
no treason and here it was it was a 280
page book and he written it in response
to an abolitionist named Wendell
Phillips who was a very close associate
of William Lloyd Garrison and the
radical abolitionists under garrison had
basically been arguing if the
Constitution was a covenant with death
and an agreement with hell because it's
sanctioned slavery and therefore they
their motto was no union with the slave
power
they wanted to basically secede in order
to separate themselves from the say this
this is the South were slaveholders and
when but this was their argument and
then right about then in 1844 they
release Madison's notes which had been
secret Madison's notes for the
Constitutional Convention had been
secret until then and they got released
and then Wendell Phillips who is a
harvard-trained student of Justice story
read these notes and they see all these
references to slavery and so he
publishes a pamphlet called the
Constitution a pro-slavery document in
which he indict the framers they say see
we were right all along the Constitution
is evil and look at all these men these
things from Madison's notes showing that
the intention of the framers was to
protect slavery so what a Spooner do
Spooner writes a book in response called
the unconstitutionality of slavery in
which he argues framers intent doesn't
matter we're not bound by the intentions
of the framers it's irrelevant
we're only bound by the meaning of the
words they wrote we're only bound by the
meaning of the words we wrote or what
the resolution would say the public
meaning of the words they wrote and
because they actually didn't mention
slavery they used euphemisms to refer to
slavery they said persons held to
service they sometimes said other
persons but they never used the word
slavery which they they had at their
disposal they used euphemisms he says
we're not bound by the evil possible
meaning of these euphemisms were only
bound by the good ones unless they put
it in writing unless they actually came
right out and said so and this I thought
was remarkable I said this is a version
of originalism that I could actually get
behind that is we're not bound by the
intentions of the framers were only
bound by the public meaning of what they
said it took me many years before and
thinking about originalism before I
finally concluded it I think Spooner was
wrong about the Constitution and the
public meaning of the Constitution that
these words which were used as
euphemisms would in context have been
understood by the public to refer to
slavery and therefore they did refer to
slavery so I think his actual argument
was wrong but his approach I thought was
very sympathetic but unbeknownst to me
this idea of original public meaning as
opposed to framers intent had already
been advanced and proposed by Justice
Antonin Scalia before he was
justise when he was on the court of
appeals in the DC Circuit he had gone to
the Reagan Justice Department and given
him some talk saying look you guys
should stop talking about the framers
and the intentions of the framers and
start talking about original public
meaning so eventually this isn't late by
the late 90s it was reading Spooner that
persuaded me that this was a viable
alternative and I eventually concluded
that I myself was an originalist in part
I've been doing a lot of work on the
original meaning of the ninth amendment
doing a lot of work on the original
meaning of the second amendment and I
had to ask myself after a while why did
I care about the meaning of this if I'm
not an originalist and why do all my
audiences care so much about the
original meaning of these provisions if
they're not originalist and that
eventually I reconcile myself with
originalism and became one so let's talk
about what originalism is and why we
should be originalist why we should
interpret the Constitution according to
its original public meaning all right so
I've got a copy of the Constitution here
you can all see it it's an actual real
thing and what is this thing what is
this thing well here I'm going to tell
you what this is and it's not
necessarily what you expect this is not
the law that governs us this is not the
law that governs us we don't consent or
agree to this law this is one of
Spooner's earlier points as you remember
from no treason we don't consent we're
never asked to consent what is this
document this document is the law that
governs those who govern us this is the
law that governs those who govern us so
then and how do we know that how do we
know that we know that because unlike us
who were not asked to consent each and
every person who governs pursuant to the
powers created by this document takes an
oath a personal oath to follow this
Constitution and I'm going to read you
what that oath says it's right in here
in this Constitution it says this is
article 6 section of section 3 the
Senators and Representatives
before-mentioned and members of the
several state legislatures in all
executive and judicial officers both of
the United States and of the several
states shall be bound by oath or
affirmation to
port this constitution this constant not
the Constitution this constitution the
written one alright so if this is the
law and that so each that's a unanimous
100% consent by those who are empowered
by the Constitution to follow this
constitution so what does that entail
that entails that the people who are to
be bound by this law can no more change
the meaning of the law that governs them
without going through the appropriate
change process which is defined in this
constitution by by by Article five then
we can change the laws that are imposed
upon us without going through the
legislative process so that when we run
into a speed limit we are bound to obey
that speed limit even if it's an
unreasonably low speed limit we're not
allowed to adopt a living speed limit or
a speed limit at the moment speed of it
without going through the legislative
process and the same thing is that's
true for us and the laws that are used
to bind us is true for the law that's
used to bind them and that simply yields
the following proposition the
Constitution the meaning of the text of
the Constitution should remain the same
until it's properly changed the meaning
that's it that's originalism by the way
in one sentence the meaning of the
Constitution should remain the same
until it's properly changed by amendment
so that means in order to figure out
what the text is I mean it is we see
what was it what did it mean when it was
enacted in 1787 in 1789 when the
Constitution was enacted in 1791 when
the first ten amendments were added to
it in 1768 when the 14th amendment was
ratified what did it mean then and
therefore that's what it means today
unless it was properly changed okay so I
only have two minutes left I want to
stick with in my time so I want to this
morning on his blog Professor Dorf had a
nice blog post about tonight's debate
and here's what he said on this blog
post he said for my's perspective
quote from my perspective far better 9
justice courses than one president Trump
I probably am not gonna argue with her
about that Mike alright but let's start
over
from my perspective better 9 justice
corsages than 1 President Trump I wish
that my conservative friends would
accept the converse better 9 Ginsburg's
than one Trump all right so that's what
he said today with all due respect Mike
I think that this is the wrong question
to ask I think in light of this debate
this is the wrong question to ask so so
here's the question I think that I would
leave you with and see what you think I
would think would you rather that Donald
Trump appointed nine justices who
believed who share Donald Trump's values
and believed in a living Constitution in
which they can change and update this
Constitution so that it actually
reflects their values would you like
Donald Trump to appoint that those
justices or would you rather that he
appoint not eight more justice gore
searches who would actually follow the
original public meaning of this text
whether it cut in the right or whether
it cut to the left Thanks thank you
thank you professor Bernette professor
Dorf it's a great pleasure to be here
tonight I have a confession I am NOT a
libertarian full-stop although I am a
civil libertarian and many of my best
friends are libertarians so I want you
to begin by imagining that we had a
different resolution before us today
suppose the resolution were about
something entirely different
I suppose it said driverless cars should
be legal on all roads in the United
States and the speaker who was promoting
the resolution got up and told you a
very nice story about how he came to be
in favor of driverless cars and then in
his final three or four minutes said and
you know of course driverless car
technology isn't quite where it needs to
be just yet if we allow it to be fully
legal on all US roads today we'll have
mayhem
and therefore when I say driverless cars
should be legal all I mean is that
people should be able to use cars
equipped with GPS units right you would
say that that speaker had pulled a fast
one
likewise if this were 2002 or 2003 and
we were debating the resolution the
United States should invade Iraq and the
party with the affirmative told you a
heartwarming story about people in Iraq
and then said and therefore we should
invade Iraq with economic aid and with
kisses
you would say you're not defending the
resolution the resolution today is the
US Constitution should be interpreted
and applied according to the original
meaning communicated to the public by
the words of the text what I wrote in
the part of the blogpost that Randy
didn't tell you about and I assume you
haven't already in the intervening 30
seconds or so is that the reason why I
think better nine justices Gorsuch than
one president Trump is because this kind
of debate has such low stakes when
original public meaning is defined in
the way that Randy and many of his
friends define it now that's good from
my perspective right I would much rather
have people who claim to be original
ist's actually defending a living
Constitution as Randy has just done for
you then to have them defending original
intent and original concrete expected
applications as people who called
themselves originalist s-- in the late
1970s 70s and early 1980s did why
because Randy and I are in complete
agreement that the way to figure out the
answer to our contemporary problems is
not to ask what would James Madison have
thought about whether attaching a GPS
tracker to a car is a search or thermal
imaging is a search that's an absurd
question right that's not the right way
to go about construing any law rather
what we have to do is to figure out what
the
I mean we agree about that but Randy is
knocking on an open door when he says we
are bound by the text nobody thinks that
the text of the constant the courts are
empowered to change the text of the
Constitution the debate between people
who call themselves originalist s-- and
everybody else is about whether that we
can discern that meaning by staring hard
at the words or whether we need to apply
our own understanding of the world in
which we live now you don't have to take
my word for that here's James Madison in
Federalist 37 all new laws and he's
talking about the ratification of the
Constitution here so he includes the
Constitution in laws all new laws though
penned with the greatest technical skill
and passed on the fullest and most
mature deliberation are considered as
more or less obscure and equivocal until
their meaning be liquidated their
meaning be liquidated right they don't
have a fixed meaning originally because
the wealth of problems that confronts
human beings is so great that the words
can't capture all of the answers right
so the meaning has to be liquidated and
ascertained by a series of particular
discussions and adjudications now what
does that mean in practice it does not
mean as Randi suggests and as people
parody people who believe in the living
Constitution suggest that nine justices
sit around and think what would I like
to replace the Constitution with what
they do inevitably is they start with
the text of the Constitution they look
at how it's used in context so the
reason why we can say that although we
sympathize with Lysander Spooner
understanding of the words by the
absence of the word slavery you look at
the whole structure of the Constitution
you say it's not realistic in light of
what we know to impute to the people who
adopt it and ratify the Constitution the
the meaning that slavery is illegal nor
would it be a reasonable interpretation
for us
Randee asks what is it that makes the
Constitution law and he said he tells us
what doesn't make it law what does it
make it law is the fact that a bunch of
people over 200 years ago many of them
not related to us from an exclusive
group of the population ratified it we
were in complete agreement that that's
not what makes it law so what does make
it law well we have different answers to
that question Randy thinks that what
makes it law is that it promotes the
virtues of a good society as he explains
in one of his books I can quote you from
that in a little bit but let me tell you
why what I think makes it law what I
think makes it law is simply the fact
that it's accepted around here as law
the best jurisprudence book ever written
was written by an English legal scholar
named hla Hart it's called the concept
of law and what Hart tells us is that
the law consists of primary rules those
are the rules like the speed limits that
affect all of us and secondary rules
rules that govern the people who govern
us and behind all of this is a so-called
rule of recognition think of it instead
of lord of the rings' fashion one rule
to rule them all right the the rule of
recognition is what grounds the whole
thing and that is ultimately a matter of
social practice it's a matter of social
practice among governing officials and
so forth and so what makes the
Constitution have any authority at all
is the fact that it's accepted but
what's accepted is not necessarily its
original public meaning not because the
judges have changed the original public
meaning but because the original public
meaning is radically indeterminate on
all sorts of questions here are just a
list of questions I thought are in the
air these days that the Constitution
might be invoked to answer can a sitting
president be indicted can a president
pardon himself does Congress have the
power to requires state and local
officials to enforce federal law does
the Second Amendment protect an
individual right to possess firearms
through the 5th 9th and 14th Amendment's
protect a right to abortion does the
Eighth Amendment permit the death
penalty and if so when for juveniles if
watch the age cutoff some of these are
questions the Supreme Court has answered
some of them are questions the court
hasn't yet had the opportunity to answer
and may never answer but when the court
looks to contemporary values and
discovers that the meaning is different
from what people who if they thought
about it might have had a view about
this in the late 18th century or in 1868
if we're talking about the 14th
amendment when the justices do that they
are not changing the meaning sometimes
the meaning just gets liquidated let me
give you two examples so this is a
libertarian forum so I want to talk
about two two areas where I think we
agree where we share the value the first
is the value of freedom of speech right
what it is that enables you to put what
you want on your blog and not have to
face punishment in the 18th century the
phrase freedom of speech was generally
understood not by everybody there were
two centers but to the extent that we
can find a shared meaning the phrase
freedom of speech generally meant that
the government could not require prior
press licensing right so that's a speech
and the press it's the idea that Milton
puts forward a narrow política it's an
important principle but it's very very
far short of our modern conception of
freedom of speech the modern conception
of freedom of speech evolves in the
early 20th century in a series of
dissents by justices home and Brandeis
and eventually gets recognized by the
Supreme Court first but with the
Liberals in the 1950s and 60s eventually
with the Conservatives in the 8th in the
1980s and 1990s to where it has become
an article of faith that thankfully
there is a cross ideological consensus
on it's not because the framers had a
robust conception of freedom of speech'
that anybody at the time would have
understood such a robust conception it
is a modern invention not invented by
the judges but understood by the people
when I said HL a heart has this idea
that what we accept that that we accept
the law what we accept is the law as
we've come to understand it and he
didn't invent this idea Joseph's story
and his commentaries on the Constitution
in the early 19th century says the same
thing he says you don't look to the
hidden meanings because it's what the
people accept the fact that the people
that there's no Equal Rights Amendment
in the Constitution is a reflection of
the fact that our contemporary society
accepted women's equality and so there
was no need to amend the Constitution
under Randy's approach who would say did
the framers of the of the 14th amendment
understand that they were adopting a
principle of sex equality or did those
who did those words communicate to them
a principle of sex equality of course
they didn't how do we know that we know
that because another provision of the
very same 14th amendment for the first
time in the Constitution introduces a
gender line it tells the southern states
if you want to disenfranchise people
based on various characteristics and
everybody knew that meant race you can't
do so absent losing some of your
representation of in Congress and how do
we and how is that defined it's by the
male inhabitants so the very people who
wrote male inhabitants in the 14th
amendment almost certainly would not
have understood the words equal
protection to encompass at prohibition
on sex discrimination now Randy's about
to get up here and tell you uh-huh
but they didn't say equal protection and
their own in sexist views they said
equal protection and what he's going to
argue for is living constitutionalism
all right he's going to tell you you can
have your cake and eat it too so the my
fundamental argument with Randy is not
so much that he's wrong but that he's
facilitating a bait-and-switch
he gets up here and promotes what he
calls originalism by appealing to the
virtues of the living Constitution but
then having done that people at large
not the erudite members of this audience
but people think AHA that smart
georgetown law professor has showed why
originalism is right and then they go
use it to instantiate the old bad
version of originalism that randy has
has discredited properly now when I get
up again I'll give you a couple of
examples of that ripped from today's
headlines but now it appears sadly that
my time is up
[Applause]
Thank You professor Dorf
professor Barnett will take the
challenges that have been laid to him in
his rebuttal now that was great Mike I
expected I expected no less from you
he's a great debater here's there's a
lot there to talk about let me just try
to start with this it would make a
difference if the 9th amendment were
enforced according to its original
meaning it would make a difference if
the privileges or immunities clause was
enforced according to its original
meaning it would make a difference if
the Commerce Clause was enforced
according to its original meaning if the
Necessary and Proper Clause was enforced
according to its original meaning if the
second amendment was enforced according
to its original meaning it would make a
difference if the contracts clause was
enforced according to its original
meaning I unlike this morning which it
wasn't by a vote of 8 to 1 with justice
score such the sole dissenter it would
make a difference if all the parts of
what I in my previous book called the
lost Constitution were actually restored
and that was the name of the book the
restoring the lost Constitution I didn't
mean restoring some old constitutional
law from pre 1937 I meant restoring the
clauses of the Constitution that caused
me to completely turn off of
constitutional law because the Supreme
Court had ignored them and if it didn't
make a difference Mike if it if those
provisions are so open-ended that they
could be construed to mean anything that
we want them to mean then why did they
have to be redacted why did they have to
be blotted out and basically they are no
more why can you not go into court and
argue any of
those provisions and prevail because the
meaning of those clauses did make a
difference and they had to be gotten out
of the way in order to turn the kind of
Republican Constitution that we had into
a democratic constitution of the kind we
now have and that is the title of my
book our Republican Constitution the
thesis of my book our Republican
Constitution so Michael tells you that
nobody says that we should disregard the
text well I can think of two people who
have said something like that one is
Professor David Strauss who's the author
of the book the living Constitution who
has adopted what's called a common
there's lots of different variations on
living constitutionalism by the way
there isn't any one in fact you really
don't know what you're going to get from
a living constitutionalist until they
open their mouth and tell you because it
could be almost anything but there but
one of the variations on this is
common-law constitutionalism and I think
professor Dorf is actually sympathetic
with this particular version and here is
what David Strauss the author of the
living constitute the book the living
Constitution said in a Harvard Law
Review article just a couple years ago
he said provisions of the text of the
Constitution are to a first
approximation treated in more or less
the same way as precedents in a common
law system the effective constitutional
provisions is not fixed at their
adoption or for that matter at any other
time instead like precedents provisions
are expanded limited qualified rican
sieved relegated to the background or
all but ignored depending on what comes
afterwards on subsequent decisions and
on judgments about the direction in
which the law should develop that's how
he defines living constitutionalism and
in a Harvard Law Review book review of
this book here's what Professor Dorf
says about at the end of his very long
and very thoughtful and I highly
recommend his book review by the way
it's a book review of that book in a
book by Jack Balkan and here's how he
said this is how he concludes he
recommends that quote genuinely
progressive movements do better to use
the Constitution if at all strategically
and even disingenuously and that they
should not quote succumb to the American
cult of constitution worship
so I'm not exactly sure what he means by
that he'll tell us that when he rebuts
what he meant by that but I think I'm
pretty sure what just what what
Professor Strauss means by this but that
is basically that the text of the
Constitution is optional and what really
depends on whether the judges today
think we should follow it or we should
not follow it that is living
constitutionalism regardless of which
variation of living constitutionalism
you have and it would make a difference
I think if we were to follow the actual
meaning of the whole Constitution not
just the favorite parts that we've been
left with which changes the nature of
the Constitution itself I guess the last
thing I just want to talk about before I
sit down is what he said about what
makes law and he said he was going to
say some give some quotes from my my
work so I'll try to fill in that fill
out in that footnote for you
he cited HL a Hart who is a great man in
his book the concept of law was is a
classic work about about what makes law
law it is a positivist conception of law
which means law is according to a chart
based on simply what is accepted it's
not based on what is just or what is
right I personally agree with this Atlit
the aspect of I know what the law is I
can tell what the law is whether it's
any good or not is another matter so in
that sense I kind of agree with that
idea I when I was a prosecutor I could
tell what the law was and I can tell
what the law is today I can tell that
the law is for example if the Second
Amendment doesn't mean very much even
after Heller that the Ninth Amendment
doesn't mean very much I know that
that's what today's law is but then the
question is the real question is is the
law that's imposed upon us binding in
conscience on us not whether it's the
law but whether we have any moral duty
to obey that law that's really the
question and the answer that I give in
my work is that we have a moral duty to
obey the law if there is good reason to
believe that those laws that were
enacted
we're both necessary to the protection
of rights and proper that they're both
they are proper insofar as they don't
violate our rights and they are
necessary for the protection of the
rights of others
we have good reason to believe that the
laws were enacted for that reason that
we have a good reason to follow the law
and a duty to follow the law the same
reason we have to follow the rights that
our fellow citizens have we have a duty
to respect the rights of others and so
the duty comes indirectly through the
law if the law is necessary and proper
for protecting the rights of others and
then in order to answer that question
you have to ask do we have a legal
system of the kind that can produce laws
of that sort I think that as amended we
the Constitution if followed could be
that legal system but the Constitution
is not followed and so at that point I'm
not sure that the laws that emerge from
it carry with it a duty of obedience but
that's a separate question from what
exactly the law is now where did I get
this idea from is this just my crazy
libertarian idea I would say that this
idea is the political philosophy of the
United States of America it is the
American political philosophy that was
enunciated in our founding document and
our founding document was not the
Constitution of the United States nor
was it the Articles of Confederation it
was the Declaration of Independence
which created us as a separate polity
and the Declaration says of course as
you know we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal and they are endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
among which are the rights the
individual rights to life to liberty and
to the pursuit of happiness those are
each and every individual rights and in
the very next sentence it gives the
American theory of legitimate government
and the next sentence says to secure
these rights governments are instituted
among men deriving their just powers
from the consent of the governed to
secure these rights so the question we
have to ask ourselves is is this a
structure that can secure these rights
if followed if your answer to that is if
followed they that's not a good enough
structure for that
well then you would say the laws that
are imposed upon us are not morally
binding but if you think that if
followed this is a structure that could
produce laws that are necessary to
secure the rights of each and every one
of us each and every one of us we the
people each and every one then you'd
have to say this is a document that's
worth following
but the question is are we following it
now and the answer is we are not thank
you professor Bernette professor
Dorothea rebuttal Randi paid me the
backhanded compliment of saying that I
was a excellent debater which is a way
of saying that I was making the weaker
argument seem the stronger as Plato's
gorgeous is accused of doing but I want
to pay him a genuine compliment I want
to I want to compare Randi to John
Stuart Mill as you know Mills Mill was
us in some sense the founder of
libertarianism wrote a great book on
Liberty Mill was also a great
utilitarian that is to say he followed
in the Benthamite tradition and he
refined Bentham's idea to say that there
are higher pleasures and lower pleasures
and Mill claimed that he derived his
libertarianism from his utilitarianism
but it was not true he happened to be a
utilitarian and he happened to be a
libertarian you can't derive
libertarianism from utilitarianism if
you believe truly in utilitarianism
you'll think that it's ok when the 5
people needing transplants come into the
hospital it's permissible to sacrifice
the president for an appendectomy to
take his his organs and give them to the
different people that violates people's
rights but a certain kind of utilitarian
would say that's ok
Randy's the same way he was a
libertarian before he became an
originalist and he's a libertarian after
he became a originalist it's not because
he's driving libertarianism from the
Constitution although I believe he
sincerely thinks he is instead what's
going on is like lots of other people
who believe strongly in the living
Constitution he is reading libertarian
values into it now there's no doubt that
the framers were influenced in ways by
libertarian thinkers including John
Locke but they were principally
different from us
modern libertarianism is an invention of
the 19th and 20th centuries it's not
simply Locke's view that got adopted by
the framers there's a great deal of
literature on this I talked about the
first moment before I said there was a
second example the second example I'll
give you is
the takings Clause the original meaning
of the takings Clause which is the the
Clause of the Fifth Amendment that
limits the power of eminent domain says
the government has to pay just
compensation was that it did not apply
to what we now call regulatory takings
so if the government actually took your
property they had to pay you just
compensation but if instead they
regulated it in such a way that you
couldn't use it at all for any economic
benefit most scholars including the
current dean of the Georgetown Law
School well argued that the framers
would have thought that's fine why
because the framers were what we would
now call at least as much Civic
Republicans as they were libertarians
and so if you want a libertarian
Constitution adopt a libertarian
Constitution but don't pretend you're
getting it through the original meaning
of the Constitution now one of the
things Randi said was that living
constitutionalists will often you know
that he doesn't you know what they're
gonna say to lay it out there
that's true of originalist s-- as well
the thing that I said in that Harvard
Law Review book review about not pretend
you know using the Constitution
disingenuously that was not a discussion
of Strauss that was discussion of the
other book that I was reviewing a book
by Yale Law Professor jack balkan with a
provocative title living originalism in
which Balkan argues without apparent
intended irony that living
constitutionalism and originalism are
really the same thing now various
originalist have tried to kick balkan
out of the originalist club because he
has publicly admitted that the emperor
has no no no clothes but the truth is
he's right except that as I told you it
is a kind of Swit a bait-and-switch let
me give you two examples Justice
Clarence Thomas is perhaps the most
originalist justice on the Supreme Court
and yet he frequently invokes the words
public meaning originalism but then he
shifts into old style original looking
at what the framers and ratifiers
expected and intended a good example of
that is a case involving violent video
games from California number of years
ago in which Justice Thomas wrote a
dissent saying there can't be a First
Amendment right to sell violent video
games to minors because
the framers didn't think that there was
a right for strangers to talk to minor
children and that's not about what the
words freedom of speech meant in 1791
it's about what people expected it's the
old-style originalism I'll give you
another example ripped from today's
headlines all right today the Supreme
Court decided 8 to 1 that the contracts
clause did not forbid Minnesota from
changing its default rule with respect
to the who the beneficiary after a
couple gets divorced and one of them
dies in an insurance contract so
complicated case not worth going into
justice Gorsuch dissents and he says you
got it wrong the the problem here he
said is if we look at the original
public meaning the original public
meaning of the contracts clause was it
would have forbidden at that what's his
evidence he tells us what the framers
thought he recites a debate about the
ratification it's the subjective
intentions right there's that bait and
switch you talk about original public
meaning in these sort of fora but then
when it comes to it you do the
discredited form of originalism finally
you can't beat somebody with nobody it's
not my job to persuade you to be come
living constitutionalist it's just my
job to persuade you not to vote for the
resolution as randy has defended it let
me give you a few alternatives maybe you
believe in that old religion right the
old-style originals if you do fine then
you should vote against the resolution
maybe you believe in judicial restraint
maybe you think that the best way for
the Constitution to be interpreted is
for judges to get out of the way and
only to overturn the political branches
where they've made a clear error this
position has a long and distinguished
pedigree the most famous articulation of
it was by Harvard Law Professor James
Bradley Thayer in the late 19th century
in which he said unless this it's shown
that there's something is
unconstitutional beyond a reasonable
doubt leave the legislature alone in
modern times probably the only justice
who has practiced this was the second
justice Harlan but if that's what you
think then
vote for that that's better than Randy's
living constitutionalism disguised as
originalism um maybe you think that what
we really value is the stability of the
law Columbia Law Professor Tom Merrill
wrote a very influential article a
number of years ago promoting what he
called Burke not Bork
he said we should be traditional
conservatives about this if you adopt
originalism
you won't be preserving the law if
you're going if you're you'll be you'll
be undoing all of these settled
precedents and we should have a more
common law approach another example the
late John Hardy Lee Dean of Stanford Law
School promoted what he called
representation reinforcement he said we
can't trust the political process to
protect the rights of minorities in
freedom of speech but otherwise we can
and so only intervene judges when you're
promoting democracy finally some people
who call themselves originalism say we
should just follow the law will bowed at
the University of Chicago Law School is
an example of that he thinks this is a
version of originalism what it really is
is a collective sysm the justices don't
pay fealty to any particular brand of
originals or otherwise if you agree with
any of those or anything else then you
have to vote against the resolution
[Applause]
unless you're in law school or legal
academia you might not realize that
you've just listened to two of the
finest minds in legal academia today
on both side on both sides of a very
complex issue who really do like each
other
so well while you are composing your
questions and even though I can't see
you there is a because the lights are so
damn bright in my eyes there is a
microphone sort of to my left and your
right I'm going to take the chairs
liberty and pose some questions to my
colleagues professor Barnett shortly
before he died the Pope of originalism
that's Justice Scalia confessed that he
was a soft-hearted originalist when
confronted with things like well under
the Constitution's original public
understanding a horse thief could be
branded on the face what would you do
Justice Scalia if the state of South
Dakota or Montana reinstituted facial
branding for horse thievery he resorted
to his soft-hearted originalism that if
it made his stomach turn he wasn't going
to be in favor of it remaining seated
because you're entitled to rest a little
bit
professor Barnett would you address the
soft-hearted originalism of Nino Scalia
yes well actually wrote an article after
he voted against us in the rage case I
was the lawyer that brought the Gonzalez
versus rage lawsuit on behalf of the
citizens of California wanting to use
medical marijuana and the government
said that they could regulate this
growing of a plant in your backyard
under its interstate commerce power
that's reading that's that's reading a
lot into the interstate commerce power
and Justice Scalia voted against us and
I was a little annoyed by this and so I
took out my I can't there was no other
way for me to strike back at a Supreme
Court justice other than to write an
article and I wrote an article called
Scalia's infidelity a critique of
faint-hearted originalism and what I
said in that article was that Justice
Scalia did commit and in fact I think
although he did by the way near the end
of
life say that he wasn't a faint-hearted
originalist but I think look I think he
did use what you would call multiple
modalities he did do something that
Michael Dorf I think rightly criticizes
and that is for example he used
precedent or stare decisis to overturn
the orig original meaning even when he
knew the original meaning was otherwise
and I think that that was wrong I mean
the in the Macdonald case which applied
the right to keep and bear arms to the
state's the appropriate part of the 14th
amendment by which that should be done
is the privileges or immunities clause
which says no State shall make or
enforce any law which shall abridge the
privileges or immunities of citizens of
the United States that sounds like
that's really important doesn't it but
guess what the Supreme Court disregarded
that provision in 7 1873 and is not
adhere to it since
and Justice Scalia when Allen Gura the
lawyer in that case argued that this
should that he should enforce the right
to keep and bear arms under the
appropriate provision Justice Scalia
made fun of him in open court saying
what are you doing bucking for a
position on a Law School faculty yes
it's called it the darling of the
professorial that is wrong that was
wrong that was wrong behavior in Justice
Scalia in my opinion and he shouldn't
have it mocks somebody for asserting
part of the Constitution and so look
we're all flawed and we all make
mistakes and I have no heroes on the
Supreme Court I don't even have any
heroes looking back in history on the
Supreme Court possibly the first Justice
Harlan might be a hero of mine because
he was at the center in Plessy but other
than that I don't have heroes there all
everybody makes mistakes just as Thomas
makes mistakes justice courses is going
to make mistakes
but here's the thing Mike kritis Michael
criticizes them because instead of
adhering to this version of originalism
he's adhering to that version of
originalism the bad one but he can tell
the difference nb8 by being able to tell
the difference you have a basis for
criticism and that's what originalism
gives you a basis for criticism if in
fact the only criticism is that look he
didn't reach the result we like and we
all want different results then that is
not a basis for criticism on the basis
of
the Constitution alright professor Red
Dwarf professor Bernette brings of a
very famous case in which he was the
litigant involved in the medical
marijuana in California in which
essentially the Supreme Court found that
Professor Barnett's client angel race
who might have interviewed several times
who grew marijuana in her backyard and
used it only for her own use pursuant to
a prescription from her physician and
authorization from the state of
California she didn't sell it she didn't
move it other than her backyard somehow
was engaged in interstate commerce is
that not the height of applying a
modern-day version of interstate
commerce as opposed to what the framers
intended professor Dorf and if that is
the height of it how do we prevent
against it this is an argument that's
been going on since the founding so
those of you who aren't familiar with
American history might have seen the
musical Hamilton at least so you'll
recall that Hamilton and Jefferson were
rivals both within the Washington
administration so there was a proposal
by Hamilton and others to create a Bank
of the United States don't worry I'll
get to the question color against
Maryland yes do you create a Bank of the
United States which would have certain
powers and abilities and facilitate
various of the functions of the
government and Washington wasn't sure
that this was going to be constitutional
so he asked Hamilton whom he knew would
favor the bank to write a memo
supporting its constitutionality he
asked Jefferson and he also asked have
been Randolph and I forgot who the third
one was he has somebody else as well to
write memos against it because he really
wanted to hear the case as well as could
be argued and here's what Jefferson said
Jefferson said of course you not have
the power to create a bank there's a
list of the powers of Congress an
article 1 section 8 it's not there
doesn't say create a bank game over
Hamilton said not so fast in order to
carry out those powers but government
has to have
incidental powers one of those
incidental powers could be to create a
bank now fast-forward to 1819 it's now
the second bank of the United States
created after James Madison as president
didn't let the bank lapse and so we
almost lost the war of 1812 so now we
have the second bank of the United
States and the cases it's challenge goes
up to the Supreme Court and John
Marshall basically plagiarizes
Hamilton's memo and says the bank is
constitutional there has since the very
beginning been a battle over the scope
of the Commerce Clause and other powers
I don't really have a strong view about
that what I will say in support of
Justice Scalia's position is that he
wasn't writing on a clean slate in
addition to Hamilton and Marshall he
also had the Supreme Court that had said
you could regulate how much wheat a
farmer can grow during the 1930s under
the Agricultural Adjustment Act and he
said basically pot is like wheat if they
can tell you how much bread you can grow
then there and that's interstate
commerce then so is pot now maybe that's
right maybe it's wrong but I don't think
we can fault Justice Scalia for saying
that there is precedent and we have to
follow precedent unless it's clearly
wrong and unworkable because otherwise
every day you wake up and the whole law
can be undone alright I'm going to ask
one more question if our debaters
professor Barnett does the phrase in the
First Amendment Congress shall make no
law mean no law
yes it means no law but then the rest of
the Amendment says abridging the freedom
of speech and so you have to then ask
what is an abridgment of freedom of
speech or infringing the freedom of
speech what is an infringement of the
freedom of speech so just so no law that
infringed the freedom of speech or the
right of freedom of speech you have to
first of all define what is the right of
freedom of speech and then what is an
infringement on that right and then no
laws should be passed that does those
things but then so just being no law
doesn't give us the answer typical to do
you I make it make a more general point
in the parts of the constitution that
that living constitutionalist like to
point to as being so open-ended that
they basically don't tell us very much
there actually are more words in those
clauses than we're normally told so the
Equal Protection Clause says it's the
equal protection of the laws the due
process clause it's the due process of
law there are more words that have more
meaning and sometimes these meanings are
a little more definite than we're told
and in the case of the First Amendment
which you asked me about judge there's
the rest of the words of the First
Amendment that go along with shall make
no law professor at Dourif how do you
accept professor Barnett's challenge
that if we are not bound by the original
document what do we do if five justices
just decide that 10th amendment is just
a truism that 9th amendment is just an
inkblot nobody believes in the contracts
clause anymore because we have just
accepted a society in which the ninth
amendment in the 10th amendment in the
contracts clause are meaningless how
would we confront that so first of all
they they don't actually say that right
they don't say we just judge Bork
famously said that the ninth amendment
must be considered as though it's
written over written by an inkblot and
he said that while professing to be an
originalist so the idea of construing
provisions of the Constitution
effectively out of the Constitution is
something that people who claim to the
original ists do as well
I would also reject the premise a little
bit right that is to say Randi and I are
in complete agreement that you have to
try to construe the text right I don't
so look if I were writing a constitution
I might you know because I'm a pinko
right I might be informed by the
experience of post-war constitutional
writers who include so-called social
economic and cultural rights in their
constitution so-called positive rights
but you know I can read I can see that
our Constitution doesn't contain
so-called such affirmative rights and so
I think that this is a parody of the way
in which courts actually deal with these
questions also we shouldn't conflate
paying attention to the text of the
Constitution with the original meaning
you see that by the way and justice
corsages dissent today in the Sabine
case he says look the contracts Clause
says that the no state shall pass a law
impairing the obligation of contract it
doesn't say substantially impairing the
obligation of contracts that's why he's
dissenting well he's right about that
but of course that's just about the text
that's a textual argument nobody has
ruled out textual arguments the burden
of originalism is not to say that the
original understanding matters everybody
agrees it matters the burden is to say
that it matters more than anything else
including presidents that have built up
over centuries all right we'll start
with whoever is first there the chair
reserves the right I don't think I'll do
this to the great Thom woods but the
chair all right the chair the chair
reserves the right to modify the wording
of the question not a speech a question
professor woods so it's a living text in
other words my question as you are alive
your question is alive professor Dorf I
guess I'm unconvinced by your claim that
it's a caricature of living
constitutionalism to say that judges are
simply substituting their preferences
for the words the Constitution then how
do we account for what happened to the
10th amendment how do we go from a
Revolution fought for local
self-government Jefferson's saying the
Tenth Amendment is this cornerstone of
the Constitution half a dozen state
ratifying conventions staying saying the
federal government has only the powers
expressly delegated to it to then the
courts saying the Tenth Amendment is
merely tautological and now we have a
situation where if you take a crack
course preparing for the bar exam one of
the test taking advices of advice they
will give you is that in the
multiple-choice section if one of the
answers is the tenth amendment you know
that's wrong that's not never right that
does not sound like a living
Constitution to me it sounds like a dead
constant professor Dorf with due respect
you did not hear the text of the 10th
amendment in that question what the
Tenth Amendment says is that the power
is not delegated to canta federal
government are reserved to the states or
the people the argument that it's a
tautology is an argument that
recapitulates Madison's argument against
the need for a bill of rights and also
Jefferson's argument against the need
for Bill of Rights the idea that the
federal government is a government of
enumerated powers and what the tenth
moment literally says is if power is not
granted to the federal government it's
reserved to the states what the Supreme
Court has done in its tenth Amendment
jurisprudence is not to eliminate the
tenth men but actually to embellish it
in favor of and I don't think that wrong
in doing so but I think they propose to
embellish it in favor of a made-up
principle right it's one it's one of the
questions I asked before right can
Congress tell the states they have to
enforce federal law supreme court said
no in a case called prints against the
United States I think it's a perfectly
good living constitutional principle
that Congress can't tell the states they
have to enforce federal law you will
find it nowhere in the text of the
Constitution not least will you find it
in and you certain will find it in the
Tenth Amendment which says if the power
is not delegated the federal government
well here it is a power that's delegated
the federal government that they're
talking about in the particular case and
so it's just not true
that the court has read the Tenth
Amendment out and people using any
variety of constitutional methods can
reach results that they want I have a
further kind of but I'm going to stop
because I want other people's questions
maybe give Randy Thomas to respond
thank you a question for professor
Barnett please Thank You professor
Bernette you said that man
notes were kept secret until 1844 if if
I'm correct correct me either one of you
I'm not a constitutional lawyer or a
historian but that at the time of the
Constitutional Convention it was a
continent Continental Congress meeting
at the same time the Constitutional
Convention was directed to propose
amendments to the Articles of
Confederation which basically if any
changes were to occur if I understand
correctly all states all 13 had to agree
yet the Constitution too would take
power once 9 ratified it now what I
understand in law is that fruit from the
poison tree is poisoned so if you are
going to say and are going to argue
originalism shouldn't then you should
all also argue that the Constitution is
actually an illegal document and fruit
from the poison tree
professor Barnett after all this are you
are you loyal to a poisonous tree look
this is an interesting question and I'm
familiar with the question and I'm
familiar with the period I don't I don't
have the time to refute this claim that
the Constitution was illegally ratified
I will just simply say that the
convention that took place in
Philadelphia was a convention of the
states that in fact the commissioners
that went to that convention didn't most
of the commissioners were authorized to
do what they did and in fact in only it
took a unanimous vote to get into the
Union in the sense that it's true the
Constitution which would get would get
up and running if if three-quarters of
the states adopted it but no state would
join the Constitution unless they
adopted it and for two years North
Carolina and Rhode Island stayed out of
the Constitution
so when ultimately was adopted by all
the states
unanimously adopted by all the states or
they wouldn't wouldn't have been forced
to stay in it all right beat but vote I
agree with that by the way yeah so but
here's the thing I don't make an Arg
from Authority about why we should
follow the Constitution I don't think we
should follow the Constitution because
they because it was because the people
that then that lived then have authority
over us today I say we should follow the
Constitution because we here we here
today are bound or we here today are
subject to the laws that are made by
people who take an oath to follow that
text however it came about that's the
oath they take and they only get the
power they are given in return for them
making that oath and if as Lysander
Spooner once said in fact in talking
about people who make O's if the if the
oath they take is to follow the
Constitution whatever they themselves
personally may decide that it means that
is literally a Spooner set an oath to
nothing and we but in return for that
oath we give them that power no they
have to live up to their oath and they
have to uphold this Constitution meaning
the written one regardless of how it
came about a question for professor Dorf
[Music]
what does the Second Amendment mean if
anything we'll let the Pitt well let the
pinko go first self-described
self-described pinko for whom I have
great respect and affection so let me
let me give you one what I think is that
is the best understanding of the Second
Amendment so at some point a number of
years ago I looked into what I could
find about the original understanding
what I found was the phrase bear arms
was overwhelmingly but not exclusively
overwhelmingly used in the time of the
adoption of the Constitution to mean
military service now the second of it
also refers to keep and bear arms and so
you could say that means you have a
right to private storage of that but for
the most part it does look like the
Second Amendment was a bit of a puzzle
because the big gripe that people had at
the time was that the original
Constitution would give the Congress
that power to create a standing army and
they were famous are very much against
standing armies now the reason the
second one is a puzzle is because it
doesn't forbid Congress from creating a
standing army contract government still
has that power and indeed can Nash
lies state militias and since the the
militia Act of nineteen hundred or so
they do that routinely so it's a bit of
a puzzle but sir Omar at Yale has a very
I think interesting read on the history
which is by the time of the adoption of
the Fourteenth Amendment in 1868 the
view that Randy takes of the second
Amendment which is that it protects an
individual right to keep your firearms
for personal self-defense and maybe for
some other purposes hunting et cetera
but that that that view had taken hold
so if you add if you take the position
that the Constitution should be read to
mean though what it communicated to the
public at the time and I think the best
reading is there is no individual right
of firearms against the federal
government
but there may be against the states
because that's what gets incorporated by
the 14-minute one final point is that my
view is a little idiosyncratic which is
I think there is a natural right of
self-defense which is probably protected
by the Ninth Amendment independent of
you are really appealing to the Guru of
the ninth amendment now when you say
when you say natural right now what you
say about the 14th amendment let me just
say this about the the Second Amendment
please because I was just a big topic
with lots of evidence in the 1960s when
the gun control debate started there
came there was a developed a theory that
the Second Amendment the right to keep
and bear arms the right of the people to
keep in their arms meant the right of a
state to have a militia that's it was an
argument that got going in the 60s most
but not all circuit courts of appeals
eventually accepted that argument in the
70s in the 80s
serious scholars went to work including
progressives like sandy Levinson of the
University of Texas and really produced
a tremendous amount of evidence that
showed that it really did not was not
anything about a right of states to have
a militia in fact that would be a very
strange way for the founders to have
written it it was about a right of
individuals like all the other rights
that are the belong to the people that
are in the first ten amendments they're
all individual rights the rights that
belong to the people in response to that
but the time the case that of United
States versus Heller came up and
interpreting the Second Amendment by
this time those people who were in favor
of the other side in favor of gun
control they had abandoned the
collective rights view they had
abandoned the collective rights view and
you know that they've abandoned it
because justice Stevens in his dissent
in Heller doesn't follow it he doesn't
say that the meaning of the Second
Amendment is the right to poll of states
to have a militia he says it protects an
individual right to bear arms in a
militia that was a completely newly
developed theory that developed in the
2000s - responded art to evidence that
had been developed in the 80s in the 90s
and so that is the state of the debate I
think the evidence is overwhelming that
it's an individual right but that does
not mean that the right cannot be
regulated just as the right of freedom
of speech is regulated by time place and
manner regulations of speech for example
what matters is that they be reasonable
regulations and not regulations that are
designed to suppress a right with which
the government disagrees which is
unfortunately what many gun control laws
proposed are about next question please
for for either of our participants my
question is for professor Barnett the
article one says that all legislative
powers are invested in Congress our
vested in Congress does that imply that
the there's originalism imply that the
entire administrative regulatory state
at a federal level is unconstitutional
first of all it's very important that
the first sentence of our article 1 says
all legislative powers herein granted
are given to Congress which is which is
one reason why the tenth amendment was
thought to be superfluous because the
first sentence of article 1 already says
that all Congress only has the powers
herein granted herein means herein what
means here in this booklet here in this
that's what it meant so and that's how
federalism is preserved under this
document because only Congress only has
all those powers and then all the other
powers are either in the States or the
people all right
so now as for the administrative state
look the Constitution clearly
presupposes that there is going to be
departments and officers of the
departments and so a department is the
same you could call it an ADA to
Hartman of Justice there were none there
wasn't a Department of Justice until
actually much later but the idea that
there would be departments and
Department has is clearly contemplated
by the text of the Constitution and the
people who are are the cabinet officers
would actually have to make reports to
the president when he demony wants one
so there can be what you might call a
body of individuals who are there to
execute the laws that are passed by
Congress you can call that the
administrative state when we are talking
about the constitutionality of the
administrative state it is not that
we're talking about we're really talking
about whether these individuals who are
not elected and not accountable and
they're not they're not confirmed by
Congress necessarily whether they have
the power to actually make law that
binds us not whether that they can that
whether that they can make laws to
execute how how the government operates
but whether they actually can make laws
to bind us and what has happened as you
know and your question presupposes this
is that the Congress and the Congress is
really to blame for this as much as the
courts have decided to offload the
lawmaking powers to this group because
they can make more laws that way
Congress doesn't only have 535 of them
they can only make so many laws they
want to make a lot more laws than that
so they create lawmakers who are in the
administrative state to make these laws
and that's the part of the part that is
constitutionally suspect but there are
ways in which that could be fixed
without abolishing everything that
currently exists all right let me tell
you what we're going to do now each of
our debaters will have five minutes to
sum up we will start with Professor Dorf
and then professor Barnett and then
we're going to vote during the time of
the voting which is about five or six
minutes we have some folks who have been
pre designated to come up here and make
some announcements to you that I think
you'll find quite interesting so for his
closing argument professor Dorf
okay thank you so much judge and let me
just say however this comes out I've
enjoyed this tremendously it's always a
pleasure to debate these issues with
Randy or just to discuss them and I
appreciate all the terrific questions I
have a few simple points to reiterate by
way of summation the first and most
important one is don't be fooled by the
bait-and-switch that Professor Barnett
is trying to hook you with right that is
to say he wants to tell you that you can
have a libertarian Constitution because
you know you can massage these clauses
because we're not bound by the original
intentions that you get comes out the
way you want it to come out all right
that's what original public meaning
originalism is that's what Professor
Balkin admitted in his book living
originalism right if that's what
originalism is fine I'm okay with that
but don't call it originalism because
then justices on the Supreme Court and
people in public debate are going to use
the patina of respectability that you've
now created for the term originalism to
justify the bad kind of originalism that
even randy condemns second randy tells
you that you know we don't want judges
changing the meaning of the law I don't
want judges changing the meaning of the
law either but that's not what happens
and in any event there is no evidence
that adopting of a phrase originalism as
a label for your jurisprudence is going
to constrain you as a judge political
scientists not just law professors study
the Supreme Court and what they find is
that you can predict about 80 percent of
how justices on the Supreme Court are
going to vote just by coding them
ideologically right conservative
justices think that affirmative action
is unconstitutional but same sex
marriage prohibition is constitutional
liberal justice is the opposite right
it's not about their jurisprudential
philosophy it's about their underlying
values and that's not surprising nor is
it shameful because the terms of the
Constitution that matter to us are very
often unclear all right now Randy's
gonna tell you well none of those
justices is doing the right kind of
originalism they're not following my
book he's gonna tell us all right fair
enough
but it reminds me in modality and way of
argument if not although obviously not
in terms of its consequences of an
argument that you sometimes hear from
communists right so the Communists will
say you know we ought to have a
dictatorship of the proletariat where
each from his ability to each according
to his needs and you say well yeah that
was tried in the Soviet Union in Mao's
China and Cuba was a disaster and the
Communist says no no no no those were
real communist systems right so from
Randy we learn Justice Scalia no no he's
not an originalist Justice Thomas well I
read you example and I gave you an
example of the California violent video
game he's not a public meaning
originalist when he claims to be an
originalist he's doing the old bad style
of originalism looks like today just as
Gorsuch did the very same thing and so
if nobody is actually an instantiation
of the philosophy that suggests one of
two things either of the philosophy
doesn't really bind people or it's it's
not a it's not a real thing right
there's a reason why professor Balkan
called his book living originalism
finally come back to Madison right
Madison tells us right not I mean I'm
not appealing to him because he wrote
the constitutional though that's a
pretty good a thought basis for
authority
he doesn't have inherent authority
because that he I'm appealing to him
because he's such a smart guy he tells
us it's impossible for the meaning to be
baked in for
the beginning they're creating a
constitution for what was then three
million people that now governs a polity
of over 300 million people it would be
astounding if what they said would have
embedded in it answers to all of our
most pressing questions we can look to
it and of course we have to look to it
to guide us but most of these questions
are not ultimately going to be answered
by staring hard at the text and asking
well what do people think these words
meant then they didn't have a view about
our problems our problems are our
problems thank you for pressing on
professor Barnett your summation well
Michael a couple times has said that I
think that we have a libertarian
Constitution or that I read the
Constitution to be a libertarian
Constitution I really don't think that's
true
or at least it's I try hard not to read
my politics into the Constitution
because I don't think we have a
perfectly libertarian Constitution and I
don't think that you should vote
affirmative Lee for the proposition that
you're being asked to vote on because
you think that we have a libertarian
Constitution in any kind of pure sense I
mean for example let's take the Commerce
Clause I mean the cut the founders of
the the framers of the Constitution the
founding generation were mercantilist
they were not free traders and the
commerce power when I went out to do
originalist research on the meat
original meaning of the Commerce Clause
while I was doing the rage case and I
was hoping to find the evidence that
showed that the meaning of regulate in
Congress shall have power to regulate
commerce with foreign nations and among
the several states and within Indian
tribes that to regulate meant to make
regular and it did not mean to prohibit
because it really wasn't until 1903 that
the Supreme Court held that it did mean
to prohibit in a case called champion
versus Ames so I went out to show that
it meant just to make regular and not to
prohibit I found that the evidence was
that it did include the power to
prohibit and not just to regulate in
fact Madison had a phrase he used called
a prohibitory regulation and why did it
Inc why did they choose a word this I'm
not doing original expected application
I'm saying why did they choose a word
like regulate that would have included
the power prohibition and that is
because in regulating commerce with
foreign nations they wanted to be able
to stop commerce with foreign nations as
well as facilitate if they wanted to and
be able to enter into trade deals in
which they could threaten to withhold
the Commerce of the United States unless
they got a deal from another country etc
or to protect native in industries
against foreign competition I'm against
those on policy grounds just as I'm
against the tariffs that the president
is proposing now on policy grounds and
so I don't think the Constitution is a
perfectly libertarian one but here's
what I think I think first of all if it
were actually followed it would be one
of the most
libertarian constitutions as a relative
basis of any Constitution that would
actually be in existence in the world it
would be a very libertarian Constitution
though not a perfectly one and let's put
it this way it would be more libertarian
than the living Constitution that we've
been given by the justices and in some
cases by dead justices and so what
Michael and those who would follow for
example precedent that would override
the original public meaning of the text
would have you follow is not the words
of this text but in fact the words that
were written by sometimes long dead
justices in the pages of the United
States Supreme Court reporter why we
should follow those words and somehow
interpret those words according to their
original meaning and not interpret these
words according to its original meaning
is a bit of a mystery because I'm going
to go back to my original point this is
not the law that governs us this is the
law that governs those who govern us
each and every one of those people who
take an oath to follow this Constitution
the written one and those who are there
to follow this Constitution can no more
change the law that governs them than we
can change the laws that govern us
without going through the amendment
process and that means following the
whole Constitution there are no ink
blots on this Constitution I was opposed
to Robert Bork when he said that The
Wall Street Journal editorial page
editorial i's de gainst that statement
at the time he made it because it was so
outrageous that you're not going to be
able to figure out what the ninth
amendment means and so that means
restoring the ninth amendment the second
amendment the Commerce Clause the
contracts clause the privileges or
immunities clause and we could go down
the list of other clauses the recess
appointments clause which has only been
kind of followed we can go down the list
of all the clauses that the judges have
said long dead judges have said are not
to be followed and I think that we
should move back in the direction of
adhering to the whole Constitution
because if we do I think this is a
system of government it's a system of
lawmaking that's capable of making laws
that are necessary and proper to respect
the individual rights of We the People
each and every
of us thank you now I want to I want to
announce the results of the voting the
yes vote started at 59% went up to over
60% picked up one percentage point
that's the number to beat
the no vote went from 10% to 30% picked
up 20 percentage points so the Tootsie
Roll goes to the negative
[Applause]